when Jerry speaking publicly for the
first time about his and Megan Markel's
unprecedented decision to give up their
royal duties he made his comments his
first public comments at a charity event
in London last night there really was no
other option what I want to make clear
is we're not walking away and we
certainly aren't walking away from you
our hope was to continue serving the
Queen the Commonwealth and my military
associations but without public funding
unfortunately that wasn't possible well
as part of the deal Harry and Megan will
lose their most prestigious royal titles
and will no longer receive public funds
royal Anika is a royal correspondent for
The Sunday Times of London she's at
Buckingham Palace with more on this
story Roy oh good morning to you boy so
much has happened in the last week a lot
to unpack but let's start with Harry's
statement last night what is your sense
of how it's being received in the UK and
the final what the people are saying
about the final outcome that the couple
is made when it was an extraordinarily
personal statement that he gave last
night and I think what has surprised
people from it is not the frankness from
Harry but I think actually in terms of
what he said off the back of the Queen's
statement on Saturday night where she
put out a statement that you know she
said everyone was very happy with the
agreement that had been reached that she
was pleased that they'd got there and
hopefully they could move on Harry
statement last night said something
quite different
he suggested quite strongly that
actually the deal that he and Megan have
got is not what they wanted to start
with they had wanted to be able to keep
one foot in and one foot out of public
duties of royal duties and the Queen has
made it clear that wasn't possible
Harry expressed his sadness about that
last night and I think that has
surprised a lot of people why right why
can't they continue serving in a royal
capacity at this point I think the
feeling is very much from the Queen and
other members of the royal family that
because Harry Megan had made it
absolutely clear they want to be
financially independent and that means
going off and striking all sorts of
commercial deals it's just too difficult
and too toxic for the royal family to
have members of the royal family who was
still working
for half of the queen on behalf of the
government going off and using the royal
status and the royal Brandon and their
titles to strike commercial deals that
has always been a toxic combination when
royal thorns have tried that before look
at the Duchess of York a little bit with
Prince Andrew and I just think the Queen
absolutely did not want our to be
dealing with that down the line so any
idea of what these new roles might look
like outside of the royal family what
kind of deals they'll strike I mean and
the idea that they're not gonna benefit
from the the title and history if not
the the current holding of the title
seems a little bit crazy
it's just uncharted territory and
unprecedented and I think you know the
guidance that I had from the palace on
Saturday night when this when this broke
was that the deal that there are no
deals signed at the moment apart from
what Meghan has signed with Disney to do
it to do a voiceover and of course
Harry's documentary with Oprah Winfrey
which is going out a GCF Apple TV but I
think well they're absolutely clear
they're saying is they're not gonna come
become big brand ambassadors for global
names for good global companies there
was a suggestion that Meghan might be a
brand ambassador for Yvonne she of
course the designer who designed her
wedding dress the panelists are ruling
that out at the moment but the palace
aren't going to have any oversight over
the deals that Harry and Megan's strike
down the line and I think that's where
there's a very gray area the really
interesting thing about that statement
and our conversations with the palace on
Saturday night was that the Sussex royal
brand which of course is their Instagram
name it's the name of their yet to be
launched foundation there is a big
question mark over whether or not
they'll be able to use that Sussex royal
branding going forwards unchartered
territory for the royal family royal
Anika thank you very much for being with
us this morning